kühl au château de versailles et
jusqu'au 18 juin le chorégraphe maurice
béjart présente une création mondiale
enfants rois c'est un hommage au château
de versailles il ya trois enfants roi
louis xiii xiv et louis case
l'imagination de béjart fonds publics un
mélange contemporain et classique de
danse et de musique foyer de reportages
de georges bigot jean-jacques le garrec
étrange véhicule tels comment vit au
xviie siècle dans les années du château
de versailles
l'ambiance est créé les jarres est un
magicien ce n'est pas seulement un
chorégraphe c'est un raconteur
d'histoires qui prend des libertés avec
l'histoire pour notre plaisir
ici il se prend pour le jardinier le
nôtre dont on fête cette année le 300e
anniversaire tout droit sorti des
gravures du temps le roi soleil qui
inventa la première académie royale de
danse les touristes n'allait pas louper
une photo pareil
c'était l'époque de la comédie ballet
des l'époque où on faisait molière
faisais ce que maintenant s'appelle la
comédie musicale ce qui au japon
s'appelle le kabuki qui était un théâtre
à la fois dense et parlée et chantée des
jarres mélange les genres avec une
habileté qui ne surprend toujours
il fait à loisir s'entrechoquer le
contemporain et le barreau
comme chaque année tout est fait dans ce
spectacle qui évoque trois règnes
d'enfants rois de louis xiii louis 15
pour que nous retrouvions justement nos
yeux et nos rêves d'enfants les enfants
ne sont ils pas tous roi
béjart à versailles
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition